il a fait son grand retour pendant la
crise du côté 19
le savon de marseille un produit
économique naturel et désinfectants bien
pratique pour se protéger du virus
saviez vous qu'il est fabriqué depuis le
14e siècle à marseille pour se laver
mais aussi pour la lessive et après
avoir connu une période faste 19e siècle
c'est un coup d'arrêt qu'il subit à
partir des années 60 les gènes tôt ou
tard prendre au piège que le savon de
marseille par sa qualité de pureté
naturelle et toucher le clos bayram
place ave
à l'époque les produits de synthèse font
leur apparition à l'image des poudre à
laver et des gels douches la machine à
laver se démocratise au placard le gros
bloc de savon résultat les savonneries
traditionnels disparaissent pour cet
industriel l'âge d'or du savon de
marseille s'était terminée en 1973
c'était là qu'était l'origine la ou deux
générations même trois se sont succédé
pendant ce temps face à ces difficultés
certaines savonnerie traditionnelle
tente de résister au début des années 80
elle se diversifie et se lance elle même
dans la conception de lessive en poudre
et il faut bien reconnaître qu'avec son
cube de savon traditionnel la savonnerie
marseillaise avait pris un certain
retard dans la révolution technologique
en plus de cette concurrence le savon
marseillais fait face à une contrainte
celle de ne pas bénéficier d'appellation
d'origine contrôlée
résultat des usines profite de la
renommée du produit les imitations se
multiplient en 1992 ce directeur
commercial une savonnerie marseillaise
milité pour la création d'un label
et pour une appellation contrôlée de la
marque de savon de marseille
bien sûr c'est ce qui peut sauver
d'ailleurs d industrie comme une autre
on pense nous que le nom de savon de
marseille est un petit peu galvaudé dans
les années 2000 toujours pas
d'appellation contrôlée pour le savon de
marseille
pire il est même copié à l'étranger
comme en chine ou en turquie sert à ça
c'est concurrence certaine savonnerie
tentent de riposter en organisant
notamment des visites guidées de leur
établissement comme ici en 2018
le but est double faire connaître un
produit régional en voie de disparition
et sensibiliser le consommateur sur les
contrefaçons
je suis ici justement parce que je
voulais comprendre qu'est-ce que si le
vrai savon de marseille est pas le savon
de marseille chimiques comme retrouver
partout aujourd'hui le savon de
marseille n'est toujours pas labellisé
au début du 20e siècle la cité phocéenne
comptait encore 90 savonnerie
traditionnels plus d'un siècle après il
n'en reste plus que quatre
[Musique]